Okay. Something I get so excited about is new to me. Vintage.
I love collecting vintage clothes,
and I was just commiserating with a mutual of mine
about how much I love vintage wool coats.
She had this beautiful emerald green.
Emerald green coat with fur trim,
and I just so happened to decide I had to have something similar.
So I found it. I found it on Etsy.
Let's unbox it now. Does it get cold in Charleston?
Cold enough to wear, like,
multiple different wool coats?
Absolutely not. Absolutely not.
Does that matter? No.
Oh. Oh,
my gosh. Look at this.
Look at this. Oh.
Oh, my god.
Now this is so much prettier than I expected.
This is incredible quality.
Like, the beautiful lining of it,
the fur. It's in fantastic condition for vintage.
Um. Holy hell.
This is. This absolutely stunningly saturated emerald green.
Oh, my gosh.
And before I forget to tell you who I got this from,
Jane Bay folk. Folk on Instagram.
I love finding new vintage sellers,
so go check her out. This was,
I believe, a under $100. Um,
so fantastic price.
Oh, my gosh.
I might get it taken in just a teeny bit on the sides,
but I might not need to, depending on what I'm wearing underneath.
This is. Whoa! Oh,
let me button it.
I am ready
for fall.
Oh, I'm so excited.
I love vintage. I get such a thrill. I love it.